(lively orchestra music)
- Embalming students have
to understand the importance
that every face is different.
Morgan Freeman, square face.
Abraham Lincoln, oblong face.
Kanye West, oval face.
My name is James Edward Smith Jr.
I'm an instructor and clinical director at
Dallas Institute of Funeral Service,
and I currently instruct restorative art.
Restorative art class provides a skill set
to be able to take a deceased person
who has experienced trauma
to the head and/or face
and restore those features in that face,
so that the family may have an option
for an open casket viewing or visitation.
In the fifth quarter, the
students are tasked with
reproducing a sculpture of
a person that they choose
and the anatomy has to be accurate.
Students generally pick
celebrities, you know,
they're popular faces and
students tend to want to
try an recreate those.
- For my restorative art project I did
Jennifer Aniston.
- Jack White.
- Viola Davis.
- Frida Kahlo.
- I decided to do David Lynch.
- Taking on the assignment
requires each of the students
to understand the proportions
for the features of the face
here in school because it translates to
what may happen in the
actual preparation room.
It is an acquired skill.
The more you practice,
the more proficient,
the better you're gonna become.
The expectation of the family is
that this is something we
can sometimes do right away.
But we have to take into
account the amount of trauma
that the face has sustained.
We need to have as much care
when handling the deceased
as if they were in the hospital
under the care of a doctor.
I am very passionate about restorative art
because I believe it's
important for people
to have the best memory picture possible
when it's time to say goodbye.
We're tasked, as
embalmers, to help families
have the option, no
matter the cause of death,
to say goodbye to Mom or
Dad or brother or sister.
(tone chimes)